SCP-682 VS SCP-5871.
Could the knife that retroactively erases
its victims from the timeline finally remove
the Hard to Destroy Reptile from our past,
present, and future?
SCP-682 was bound in place by restraints to
prevent it from escaping and a researcher
using SCP-5871 slashed it, erasing it from
existence.
From that point on, a
CK-Class Reality Restructuring
Event occurred, and post-restructure researchers
were unable to find any traces of SCP-682.
It seemed almost like it never existed.
However, soon after this, the effects were
reversed by SCP-682’s adapting abilities.
682 returned to reality, then the test we
just described was erased from existence - as
well as SCP-5871.